Now, what you need to understand,
is that it starts with us men.
There is a huge attack on the
normal healthy family structure.
Parents spoke out at a school
board meeting hearing about
her child's class being showed a
movie with a gay character in it.
They want to make men more feminine and
they want to make women more masculine.
It's a view that celebrates destructive
and toxic behavior and hurts so many.
Your perceptions of the truth
doesn't change the truth itself.
They have identified 31 gender identities.
Think how crazy this world will become.
They want you to be confused about
what it means to be a good man.
You know, a lot of people are falling for this.